[Musik]
regierungsflieger ohne maske zerstören
die grünen unsere landwirtschaft und
herrscht in deutschland bald schon eine
ökodiktatur musste öffentlich rechtliche
rundfunk dringend reformiert werden das
sind unsere themen heute abend und damit
herzlich willkommen zu filtern a8
endlich sind wir zurück also sommerpause
ich hoffe sie haben unsere debatten
ebenso vermisst wie wir und meine gäste
heute abend sind lehrer und psychologe
josef kraus er war von 1987 bis juni
2017 präsident des deutschen
lehrerverbandes heute besorgt in der
zustand des öffentlich rechtlichen
rundfunks johannes als berufsoffizier
namen auslandseinsätzen afghanistan und
mali teil spd-bundestagsabgeordneter
erfordert bundeswehr raus aus mali ex
bunte -chefin und publizist im
beitrittsjahr riekel ihre these heute
abend geht um die öko diktatur oder ob
wir überhaupt eine habe ich bin sehr
gespannt lars bender ließ anthony robert
lee er ist landwirt und sprecher von
landwirtschaft verbindet deutschland ev
also wir haben einen echten pragmatiker
ein praktiker hier sitzen aus der praxis
und seine mission die deutschen
politiker zu mahnen davor dass
deutschland sich ernährungspolitische
abschafft und sich bald nicht mehr
selbst versorgen kann schön dass sie
alle hier sind und mein name ist nena
schick und mich stört die dreiste
doppelmoral von deutschlands macht elite
wahrscheinlich denken sie jetzt darüber
regt sich die blonde frau hier wieder
auf aber wenn sie diese bilder sehen
dann werden sie mir recht geben da bin
ich mir ganz sicher die alle bürger wir
müssen ja im flugzeug maske tragen und
werden sogar geweckt dass es mir schon
mal passiert wenn diese mal verrutscht
kein scherz aber spitzenpolitiker wie
robert habeck und auch
hauptstadtjournalisten die man hier sind
im regierungsflieger dürfen ohne maske
fliegen der grund sei dass alle einen
pcr-test abgelegt hätten wenn ich aber
einen mache nun ja da muss ich trotzdem
die maske aufziehen ich will das ja gar
nicht schlecht reden hier ich finde es
großartig wenn endlich robert habeck
sagt ach ich trage die maske nicht mehr
im flugzeug prinz am großartig wenn das
haupt journalisten tun aber warum müssen
wir bürger ist da noch tun und jetzt
jetzt kommt der super gau die masten
pflicht im flugzeug wurde heute noch mal
verschärft laut exklusiven bild
informationen will das bundeskabinett an
bord von flugzeugen
bald nun auch die fsg zwei masken
erlauben dafür weil ich mich wie das
sein kann fast ganz europa verzichtet
auf die massen pflicht im flugzeug und
jetzt geht natürlich die frage an den
spd-bundestagsabgeordneten der runde
herald freuen sie sich denn schon darauf
bald im flugzeug nur noch mit ft2 maske
sitzen zu dürfen also ich hab ja immer
eine sp 2 monster of nena weil ich nie
zwei masken bei mir habe also ich trag
noch welche da ist wahrlich nicht mit
angezogen ich würde natürlich freuen
wenn die maske nicht mehr brauchen
würden solange unsere experten meinen
wir brauchen sie muss ich das auch
akzeptieren und denkt wenn er nicht
manchmal darüber nach und fragt sich
sophie warum sind wir denn hier in
deutschland die einzigen was soll denn
dieser sonderweg ich möchte hier gerne
mal einen tweet zeigen wir haben ja
jetzt den kanzler aus deiner partei olaf
scholz ich möchte hier gerne mal zu
zeigen was armin laschet eigentlich
darüber denkt er wäre ja beinahe unser
kanzler geworden er hat dazu getwittert
denn auch ihm macht das sauer was da
eigentlich abgeht gerade und ganz
versteht er es auch nicht den schweiz
zeigen wir einmal hier und zwar sagt er
nämlich es gibt dem
infektionsschutzgesetz keine ausnahme
für regierungsflieger aber merkt
eigentlich niemand dass es fast
schlimmer wäre wenn es ausnahmen für
regierende gäbe fast ganz europa
verzichtet auf massiv licht bei zumeist
niedrigen inzidenz und warum dieser
deutsche alleingang also wenn armin
laschet ihr uns fragt warum dieser
deutsche alleingang was ist die
entgegnung weil unser
gesundheitsminister was für die beste
lösung hält ja wir werden wir haben
jetzt auch die sommerpause wir treffen
uns nächste woche zur fraktionsklausur
und da werden wir hoffentlich auch neben
allen energiefragen die wir diskutieren
werden über das infektionsschutzgesetz
diskutieren und dann würde ich mich dann
auch über die eine oder andere antwort
an freunde haben wir das ist auch fast
pervers ich meine wir haben jetzt das
oktoberfest in münchen
und da gibt es keine maske pflicht aber
wenn ich heute bin ich mit dem zug von
münchen nach berlin gefahren und musste
vier stunden diese maske tragen und als
ich sie runter genommen habe weil ich
ein stück schokolade essen wollte kamen
die zugbegleiterin und sagte bitte
setzen sie gleich wie die ihre maske auf
also noch wenn ich gekauft habe wir
kennen doch dieses doppel denken schon
aus der römischen zeit ich weiß wer von
ihnen latäng gehabt hat wie cdu-vize
bogen aus dem jupiter erlaubt das system
drin fiel nicht erlaubt aus einem habeck
erlaubt ihnen ihr mir nicht erlaubt ja
diese doppelmoral
ich erwarte von einem politiker
ob in der kategorie a b oder c der
volksvertreter ist das ja auch vorbild
für das volk ist und da kann er nicht
jetzt darum tanzen und ohne also sie
sind weiter für die massen pflicht im
flugzeug das hat damit gar nichts zu tun
aber dann ist er jetzt vielleicht sogar
ein vorbild weil er sich nicht dran hält
naja an gesetze halten dann muss es sich
mit seinem superschlauen
gesundheitsminister der ja auch oft
morgen nicht mehr weiß was er gestern
gesagt hat auseinander setzen also nein
für mich ist der herr lauterbach mit
verlaub erhalten keine kapazität vor
allem weil er so redet man redet ok hat
sich über talkshows über 40 tokios im
jahr 2021 auf einen ministerposten
hinein gelabert aber
ich glaube dass mittlerweile die
fraktion oder auch der kanzler nicht
mehr so ganz glücklich mit ihm ist
werbung für den kauf online kauf von
bestimmten
impfstoffen und so weiter also an reihte
das jetzt nicht mehr da aber ich glaube
also die masken pflicht gilt tatsächlich
im öffentlichen nahverkehr also in
fernzügen und den linienflügen das ist
jetzt natürlich ein formales argument
und ich stimme ihnen völlig zu heraus
dass quasi politikern vorbild sein
sollten ich habe zum für die
reaktivierung einer bahnstrecke der
letzten woche auch eine fahrt gemacht
eine sonderfahrt eine angemeldete
sonderfahrt und haben wir an bord
diskutiert haben wir auch keine maske
getragen es gab auch kritik dann auch
gar nicht daran gedacht aber es war halt
noch rein faktisch gesehen kein
öffentlicher nahverkehr ich gebe das
hier auch zu ja ganz schuldbewusst
hätten wir machen können warum schuld
bewusst daran schuld bewusst warum ich
selber sich wohl daher an regeln lade
politik hat sich an regeln halten sollen
auch nur filmen lassen da darf ich nicht
das hat ist mit masken nichts zu tun da
darf ich mich nicht auf einem balkon in
kiew
dem fotografieren lassen mit einem
sektglas in der hand also meine damen
und herren politiker
denken sie ein bisschen drüber nach
hättet ihr
ankommt liebe alles im verkehr dann
danzig meinetwegen irgendwo im keller
machen luftschutzkeller vielleicht ja
wie finden sie denn das argument jetzt
hier von herrn kraus politik darf aber
nur im verborgenen und wurden sie denn
auch zuletzt im flugzeug oder in der
bahn mit der masken pflicht konfrontiert
und ja auch überprüft in der bahn
tatsächlich als wie ein skiurlaub
gefahren sind aber ich kann zu dem
ganzen thema eigentlich ist ganz schnell
abrunden ich bin ja britischer
staatsbürger auch und ich habe ja
gesehen wie meine verwandtschaft und
über unser verhalten unser umgang ohne
denkt die verstehen ist einfach nicht
mehr und ich muss ja nicht so weit
fahren nach großbritannien nicht
vereinfacht nach holland polen also ich
kann es nicht nachvollziehen wir reden
über den gleichen virus oder denselben
virus sogar und deswegen sind die
maßnahmen hier einfach nicht mehr
haltbar nicht mehr nachzuvollziehen und
doppelmoral da kommen wir gleich drauf
also da ist ja nichts neues was gott
jahren sie richtig temperaturen
natürlich hier natürlich aber jetzt auch
meine frage die muss ich jetzt noch mal
stellen dass politiker herz hat
gesprochen und ich mag ja loyalität man
sollte loyal zu seinem chef seines
urlaubs und auch zum gesundheitsminister
karl lauterbach finde ich gut aber jetzt
mal dass bürger herz sprechen lassen
wenn man im zug sitzt niemand ist da und
dann kommt der controller was mir auch
dann passiert bis sie die maske auf das
kann man doch nicht mehr gutheißen oder
naja ob man das gut man kann sich fragen
ob das sinn macht na also sollten jetzt
darüber reden das infektionsschutzgesetz
läuft bis zum 18 19 dann müssen wir es
wieder verlängern aber sollten wir reden
welche maßnahmen sind machen und welche
nicht und dafür bin ich auch ich habe
zwei jahre in schweden gelebt halbjahre
unter gronau habe also auch erlebt wie
man das anders handeln kann also man
kann das durchaus mal diskutieren spd
denn eine frage noch glaubt die spd denn
dass das virus schlimmer ist in
deutschland als beispielsweise in
großbritannien
ich glaube mich dass die spd das glaubt
glaubt dass herr lauterbach glaubt
bestimmt dass das virus gefährlicher
essen ja das denke ich schon es ist ein
gewaltiges versagen und nicht nur der
schutz der regierung sondern auch der
vorgänger regierung wir haben dieses
virus jetzt seit zweieinhalb jahren und
wenn ich mir dann den evaluationsbericht
der sachverständigenkommission anschauen
160 seiten lang nur wischiwaschi er
verdammt noch mal hat man denn die
international recherchieren können was
die impfung bringt was die
nebenwirkungen sind was eine normale
medizinische maske bringt was seine fb2
ausgeprägt was kennt in der schule etwas
gebracht haben fairerweise muss man aber
sagen dass wir zumindest diese
diskussion des parlaments zurück geholt
haben wenn es ein merkel-regierung einer
regierung entschieden wurde erdteilen
die erfolgs polizei das haben wir alle
gemeinsam getan und jetzt entscheiden
die volksvertreter darüber ein guter
ergebnisse errechnete man sich mal haben
wir immer kritisiert dieser debatte die
die ministerpräsidentenkonferenz sie das
entschieden hat ich kein organ des
grundgesetzes gibt auch die
selbstermächtigung insofern ist es gut
dass in den bundestag zurück gekommen
ist aber mit den ergebnissen bin ich
nicht zufrieden das merke ich das ist
gut temperatur mögen wir hierbei fehler
war eine frage ich noch mal eine frau
rinke als fdp politikerin jetzt wie
enttäuscht sind sie denn von der fdp und
auch von marco buschmann vielleicht
ob ich enttäuscht werden also sie werden
doch nicht jetzt annehmen dass ich jetzt
hier über ein lindner oder muss man die
herzen aber es ist doch die menschen
halten sie verteilen die auch mal und
parteiausschlussverfahren ja wie gesagt
auch was ihnen nicht gefällt ja fdp
gefällt vieles an der fdp mir gefällt
vor allem dieser unbedingte drang nach
freiheit und selbstbestimmung das
betrifft ja auch mein mein thema wenn es
also und energieverbrauch geht also ich
möchte mir ja nicht von der politik in
meinem privatleben vor allem nicht in
meine
hygienemaßnahmen hineinreden lassen um
vereinzelte heute mitgebracht das thema
wo aber ja auch die fdp mit macht könnte
man sagen vielleicht gezwungen gezwungen
da erlaube ich das nochmal und deswegen
kommen wir erstmal sehr akribisch wir
noch nicht hier und heißt ist dass
mutter oder vor vier jahren
und dann können wir immer noch für
richtig
also was mich wirklich stört ist dass
die politik und ich sage jetzt mal die
politik sich so sehr in unser
privatleben hinein mich das geht einfach
nicht mehr die energie sparen glaube ich
ist jeden menschen in deutschland
bewusst dass notwendig und ich kenne nur
menschen die sich gedanken machen wo sie
mit der energie sorgfältiger umgehen
bewusst so wird erst mal ausdrücken aber
ich möchte mir nicht von herrn h wird
vorschreiben lassen wie lange ich dusche
und wie waren mein duschwasser zu sein
hat ich möchte mir von herrn kretschmann
nicht sagen lassen dass ich doch besser
statt duschen einen waschlappen benutzer
ja ein das ist eine total unnötige
geschichte denn wenn ich einen
waschlappen mich branche dann werde ich
den wohl dann in die kochwäsche geben
müssen und am nächsten tag wieder einen
neuen benutzen also was ist das für eine
energieverschwendung ich will mir auch
nicht sagen lassen dass das dass ich
jetzt mein mann meine wohnung auf eine
bestimmte temperatur hinunter dem man
muss ja ich erwarte dass demnächst die
wärme polizei auftaucht und nachschaute
mir vor wie viel haben sie jetzt 19 grad
oder ist bei ihnen etwa sogar vielleicht
20 oder um gottes wenn 21 grad wenn ich
dann muss ich dann strafe zahlen muss
ich den kaminkehrer hineinlassen wer
darf denn eigentlich das überprüfen und
ich haben sie vielleicht sogar ins
gefängnis wenn man es jetzt ganz
womöglich wer hat mich wäre wenn ich
sage ich mache 22 grad er wobei ich
wirklich betone
energiesparen und sinnvoll umgehen mit
energie ist wirklich notwendig
aber ich habe heute mit meinem friseur
mit verwirrung gesprochen und habe
erzählt dass friseure künftig nur noch
mit kaltem wasser in die haare waschen
dürfen ja da hat sie also schnell auf
gelacht und gesagt dann macht sie
einladen so ich finde es beängstigend
dass die das dass das unsere städte
abgedunkelt werden ja das denke ich kann
ich dann macht's noch durch die straßen
gehen also licht ist doch auch notwendig
um mich zu schützen und ich finde auch
persönlich es gibt
baudenkmäler wahrzeichen in einer stadt
wo sich jedes beleuchtet werden aber
diese wahrzeichen sind ein symbol für
unsere für unser zusammenleben ein
symbol auch für unsere kultur und ich
finde das wichtig dass ich die auch
nachts sehe man kann in so vielen ecken
und enden sparen aber es dann geht es
zum beispiel darum habe ich heute
gelesen wie verschiedene berufe
die kälte stufen verschiedene berufe
also wenn ich sitze dann darf ich bei 19
grad sitzen wenn ich mich dabei bewege
dann wird es auf 1817 grad und es geht
endlich besonders bewegen nur noch bei
14 grad wer stellt eigentlich fest wie
sehr ich mich beim arbeiten bw hat sich
so den titel jetzt haben wir auf
betriebstemperatur einer das habe ich
sehr viel verständnis für sie und dass
sie sich nicht in ihre persönliche
hygiene rein reden wollen da habe ich
sehr viel verständnis dafür aber wissen
sie ich glaube wichtig ist dass wir
jetzt hier als deutschland durch den
winter kommen dann gesagt wir leisten
solidarität mit der ukraine ich bin der
meinung wir brauchen jetzt von unserer
regierung macht wenn die sommerpause
vorbei ist wirklich konzepte die tauben
und die vor allem der bevölkerung keine
angst machen also ich hab das gefühl
dass einige kollegen morgens auf den
twitter knopf aufwachen und den ersten
gedanken der inso morgens in den kopf
kommt
eine liste mit der
jetzt reden wir aber über energie
wir bleiben und das macht leuten angst
ich krieg mich leute die meinen
wahlkreis zu mir kommen und sagen aber
ich hab in meinem wahlkreis verdient 50
prozent der leute 1500 euro netto ja das
heißt also wirklich keine bayerischen
die alle probleme recht denn die angst
dann die angst ich glaube die angst
müsste nicht sein wenn wir einfach ein
bisschen ruhe bewahren würden wenn wir
vernünftig was ausarbeiten würden ideen
die ausgegoren durchgerechnet sind dann
sagen würden das könnte unser weg aber
hacker sein ist doch nicht nur die
komponenten
republik kann man doch schon jahre
vorher nicht im genannten republik was
waren die grüne rebecca
wollen uns den vorsitzenden eigentlich
die männliche form mit gender zeiten von
genannte google an ticks oder oder was
man sich es ist fast noch vorher schon
bleiben einmal mehr ein volk immer ein
agogisch gesagt worden nein ich bin
jetzt bei
dieser erziehungs und gewann im blick es
ist doch vorher schon gesagt worden
farblos kennen suv farblos keinen diesel
farblos fliegt bloß nicht in den urlaub
ist nicht mehr als ein mal in der woche
fleisch und weiß der teufel was alle
aber erklären
die aber würden sie dann sagen dass wir
jetzt über den geldbeutel erzogen werden
aber auch na also den steuerten oder
original den weltmarktpreis moralischen
einfach nur da und ehrlich mir einfach
sehe das soll jetzt aus einem
billigtarif kommen zu den stadtwerken
zurück wollen gar nicht mehr angenommen
werden in meiner region 30 cent pro
kilowattstunde gas bezahlen ist eine 98
prozentige gas versorgen habe und diese
wette eben einfach nicht mehr
funktioniert noch geschlossen weiter
managergehältern preise um dem winter
machen darum brauchen wir jetzt ein
durchgängiges konzept wie wir leute mit
niedrigen einkommen entlasten
lassen möchte ich noch sagen es geht mir
nicht nur um meine sorge um die
pädagogische genannten republik dass das
war nicht allen hamas
republik das war eine serie aus dass
merck einer denunzianten republik wir
haben denunziation einrichtungen von
kommunen bekommen wo menschen in
irgendeiner stadt in nordrhein westfalen
die süddeutsche zeitung übrigens hat ist
er redakteur gemacht ja anonym melden
konnten wenn einer in der zeit als man
höchstens zwei oder vier angehörige in
der ersten carola phase entscheidung da
uns gelassen haben
republik den punkt wir müssen ja weil
ich
heute nicht geben aber ich gebe bei
meinem nachbarrecht ja nach corona ist
jetzt die energie also den die neue
prüfstelle und so erziehungsmittel
erziehungsmethode denn wissen sie ich
finde energiesparen wichtig nicht
sinnvoll sondern wichtig und ich glaube
dass die meisten menschen sich auch
dessen bewusst sein denn was ich nicht
verbraucher muss ich nicht bezahlen also
die menschen drehen freiwillig die
heizung runter sie überlegen sich ob sie
eine lange reise machen entschuldigung
ich meist menschen darunter weil sie
sich nicht leisten können diese rechnung
zu
haben ihre energiepolitik dazu muss ich
aber sagen dass es glücklicherweise in
deutschland viele viele und hilfen gibt
ja ich habe mir angeschaut was die stadt
münchen zum beispiel macht um menschen
mit niedrigerem einkommen über diese
über diesen schwierigen winter hinweg zu
helfen da gibt es also zum beispiel
wenn wenn ich die heizung nicht bezahlen
kann und
es wird mir droht das stellen wir ab den
strom und die heizung gibt es eine
stelle wo ich mich melden kann es wird
niemanden die heizung oder der strom in
münchen abgestellt da bin ich mir ganz
sicher es ist umständlich und schwierig
und ich weiß dass es für die wir die
mehrheit der deutschen sehr schwierig
sein wird das alles zu bezahlen wir
fragen aber immer außerdem habe ich mich
sowieso nur warum zum beispiel dieser
heizkostenzuschuss warum der allen
bezahlt wird ich hätte diesen
heizkostenzuschuss gedeckelt bis zu
einem bestimmten einkommen dann hätten
sie nämlich auch mehr bekommen können
den 23 100 euro wenn ich das mal dann
noch wenn ich durch die steuern
abgezogen bekommen ja das ist ja tropfen
auf den heißen stein da geht es ja vor
allem um die heizkosten der
vergangenheit und dieser weg wurde
gewählt weil er einfach einfach zu
administrieren es war sie jetzt mit dem
gehalt einfach alle menschen erreichen
der arbeitgeber zahlt es mit dem gehalt
auszahlt weniger lohnnebenkosten stark
und so haben wir es einfach gelöst quasi
ohne sie haben was beantragen muss darum
ging es sie tragen jetzt mal hier liege
er auch betroffen ist und wenn sie das
hier zu hören herr als sagt dass es zu
viel panikmache auf twitter so schlimm
würzen auch wenn sie frau regiert sind
wie sehen sie denn die lager die frage
ist ja wer macht denn die panik die
panik kommt ja wirklich überwiegend auch
von einem habeck der sagen es wird ganz
bremslicht werden oder von herrn müller
der sagt wir werden mit 100 prozent auch
nicht über winter kommen dementsprechend
weniger haben translate er
selbstverständlich also für meine
branche ist extrem bremst ich weil wir
brauchen dringend dünner und dünner also
mineralischer dünger wird mit glas
produziert den gibt es faktisch gerade
nicht aktuell egal was sie bezahlen
wollen die läger sind leer und ich
erwarte jetzt auch als normaler bürger
lösungen wir waren alle drei herren her
waren beim militär so wir müssen in der
lage leben wann kommt die lösung weil
wir haben jetzt eine neue lage ich
möchte jetzt nicht hören und ich möchte
nicht sehen dass er habe ich unter
scholz jetzt nach kanada fliegen allen
ernstes dort windenergieanlagen in
neufundland geplant werden die es noch
gar nicht gibt da gibt es gar keine jene
gene jung keine pläne kein garnichts
wunderschöne landschaft ich war übrigens
mal da müssen wir hin fahren
haben sie denn die lösungen liegen hier
bei uns in niedersachsen unter der erde
wir haben 23 milliarden kubikmeter gas
an die wir ohne flecken herankommen 2009
10 hat die bundesregierung unter frau
merkel noch eine studie in auftrag geben
können wir tatsächlich
nachhaltig so nachhaltig wie möglich
schrecken antwort ja warum machen wir
das nicht wir müssen sich auf dauer
machen aber wenigstens zwei drei jahre
bis wir in der lage sind tat sich uns
autark zu versorgen das in kanada wird
mindestens sechs jahre dauern falls
überhaupt möglich ist und wir haben hoch
steht hier lassen sich oft erst einmal
das
ganz lagen nur wenig bei zum
energiebedarf aber natürlich können wir
die aber jede und jeder kubikmeter hier
gehen hart stunde hört ja aber warum ich
frage mich auch ganz ehrlich also warum
sein was irgendwie schwierig wehrleute
anderen tracking empfehlen oder
gasförderung wenn sie selber nicht vor
der haustür haben sie wissen ja selber
energieversorger energie produktion ist
egal ob das atomkraftwerk vor der
haustür haben oder eine windmühle es
gibt immer gegenwind und keiner will's
funktioniert vom staat und da wurden die
regeln aufgeweicht und windenergie zum
beispiel da scheint mir oft dass die
regierung gar kein problem damit hat ein
bürger in windrad vor die tür zu setzen
ich will noch das ist genau so auch beim
fasching querstellen mittags windräder
bei uns ab weil der strom nicht wegkommt
und jetzt wollen wir tat sich das in
kanada in neufundland windenergieanlagen
aufgebaut werden wie die haben wir hier
vor ort warum setzen wir das nicht ein
warum suchen wir immer auf der anderen
welt und sie sagen gerade genau das
richtige was für die landwirtschaft auch
erleben im moment wir haben also
windräder die nicht an das netz
angeschlossen ja wenn da nicht die
übertragungsnetze die die höchste
netzkapazität da ist gerade nach
süddeutschland zu gering weil sich halt
seit jahren jahrzehnten dagegen gewehrt
dass die übertragungsnetze geschenkt
haben wir jetzt darum haben wir jetzt
quasi planungs beschleunigungen gemacht
um diese übertragungsnetz bei uns so
kann man sonst können wir die
kapazitäten die im norden produziert
werden ich abtransport verschweigen darf
man bei der windenergie ja keine
technikfolgenabschätzung gemacht hat das
ist ja schon seit jahrzehnten eigentlich
das große schlagwort
technikfolgenabschätzung ja wir wissen
doch das kann der landwirt
wahrscheinlich auch besser sagen dass
diese windkraftanlagen auch die böden
austrocknen wir wissen dass wir riesige
probleme haben die die materialien
irgendwann zu entsorgen wir wissen dass
milliarden von enns auf die art und
weise und greifen hopps gehen ja
insekten wird man vielleicht seltener
gestochen auch wird das ist natürlich
auch wieder die futterquelle für vögel
und so weiter und so weiter mehr da
leisten wir einen beitrag gegen die
diversität der natur aber entschuldige
ist immer der landwirtschaft hin zum
sekten geht also windenergieanlagen
werden sie nicht mehr da gibt es
interessante studie darüber aber die
wird niemals veröffentlicht schuld an
entdeckten sterben grundsätzlich die
landwirtschaft kein anderer handy damit
wir merken jetzt hier am tisch also so
ganz einige sind selbst für uns sind sie
alle nicht wenn die energie krise lösen
kann was haben sie uns denn heute als
these mitgebracht und ich würde sagen
sie haben vor allem eine besorgnis
mitgebracht an diesem tisch absolut und
wir reden über energieversorgung
jährigen über autarkie und wir vergessen
total dass wir das wichtigste gut was
wir hier in deutschland produzieren
nämlich die wichtigste energiequelle die
wir täglich zu uns nehmen die nahrung
die setzen wir gerade dramatisch aus
spiel und das ganze jetzt nicht aufgrund
der aktuellen regierung sondern auf der
fonds aufgrund der vorgänger-regierung
zehn jahren ist es so dass wir mit
verordnungen drangsaliert werden uns
wehren fußfesseln ja sogar handfesseln
angelegt und wir sollen trotzdem noch
dasselbe leisten was physisch faktisch
nicht möglich ist und solange wir uns
davon nicht lösen und wir haben nun mal
auch aufgrund der ukraine krieges aber
auch vorher schon einen absoluten mangel
an ernährung natürlich gibt es ein
verteilungsproblem aber grundsätzlich
hungern die menschen direkt bei uns vor
der haustür in nordafrika in den markt
starten es fehlen weizen mengen die
kommen aus der schwarzmeerregion
übrigens nicht raus und die ersten
schiffe die ausgelaufen sind die sind
nämlich nicht nach afrika gefahren
sondern sind auch europa gefahren nach
irland frankreich und großbritannien
also so viel zu der doppelmoral von der
wir schon mal besprochen haben und wenn
wir so weiter machen sind wir nicht mehr
in der lage dass wir uns tatsächlich
hier selbst ernähren können das ist
jetzt schon praktisch so bei obst und
gemüse haben einen selbstversorgungsgrad
von weit unter 30 prozent das würde mal
keiner hören wenn sie mit politik mit
der aktuellen auch reden da wird mit
zahlen hantiert die sind über zwei jahre
alt die sind überhaupt nicht mehr
aktuell und damit wird immer gerecht
werde oder da kommt die rechtfertigung
dass wir doch auch sind sind wir in
keinem bereich mehr wenn wir noch mal
ganz konkret hinblick wir alle und ich
möchte wirklich dass dass sie diese
besorgen wie geht es den bauern dreckig
die wir haben ein höfesterben und einen
landwirtschaft sterben wir reden hier
von familien wir reden von familien die
seit generationen das machen was für
frieden und wohlstand seit hunderten von
jahren geld und jeden tag sterben
dutzende betriebe selbst
milchviehbetriebe und wir haben übrigens
ein mangel gerade ein bild 46
milchviehbetriebe machen jeden tag die
bude zu und es muss uns klar sein anders
als bei kohlekraftwerken die wir jetzt
ja verzweifelt versuchen wieder ans netz
zu bringen macht einen
landwirtschaftlichen betrieb zu macht er
nie wieder auf und dann stehen wir
irgendwann da um die sehen ja natürlich
das wetter verändert sich total wir
sehen das bei uns auch und das ist in
anderen weltteilen genau so wollen wir
uns wirklich in der abhängigkeit begeben
von irgendwelchen diktatoren von
herrschern wie ein ball szenario der
übrigens im letzten monat mehr regenwald
abgeholzt als jemals zuvor warum denn
wohl damit er stellt sich schon auf ein
dass er irgendwann ein springen und uns
unser job ja faktisch wegnehmen das
macht die politik um uns dann zu
ersetzenden geht es wie geht es ihrem
hof speziell also haben sie auch angst
dass ihnen das aus droht also wir haben
schon vor jahren mit 23 standbein
aufgestellt wir haben noch mal ein hotel
wir haben biergarten wir backen kuchen
also wir kommen halbwegs klar weil sie
können von der landwirtschafts heute
nicht mehr länger wir können unseren hof
wir haben ein ziemlich großen hoffen
dass der ist komplett vom werkschutz
denkmalschutz der kostet viel geld und
den zu unterhalten ist mit der
landwirtschaft so nicht möglich auf 1
mit dem nachwuchs in der landwirtschaft
ja das ist ja auch schon ding wir haben
ja kein fachkräftemangel ich glaube wir
sind die einzigen industriezweig wir
sind übrigens auch der größte
arbeitgeber mit den nachgelagerten
bereiche sind landwirtschaft sind nicht
der bauer sucht frau von rtl das ist ja
oft verkannt er ist ja leider so sondern
wir haben überhaupt keinen
nachwuchsmangel wir haben die best
ausgesetzt ich kenne ja ist da ist
wirklich so wie bei ihrem wahlkreis gibt
es tatsächlich fachkräfte man auch bei
den bauern na also das holzland man als
landwirt auch genau 51 im bereich
pflanzenzucht eher weniger aber
viehzucht da ist das problem dar
handfesseln lösen und dann läuft es
jetzt gegen der analyse noch ein
schrittchen weiter wir haben gerade über
politik geschimpft jetzt schriftlich mal
nicht über politik auch wenn ich
manchmal den eindruck habe dass
landwirtschaft mittlerweile auch unter
dem einfluss von eu zu einer
planwirtschaftlichen veranstaltung wird
jetzt kämpfe ich mal auf das volk auf
die bürger ja sie wollen sich heute alle
zum feind machen herr kreispolizei
bürger gleich noch mich als
verbraucher wenig dass man so pauschal
sagen darf der deutschen verbraucher er
will immer das billigste dass das kommt
mir euch natürlich in form von
dumpingpreisen anja der deutsche
verbraucher will nicht das was
jahreszeitlich bei uns wächst und
geerntet wird sondern er will halt im
winter dann frisches obst aus südamerika
früchte
auswirkung gemüse aus südafrika und so
weiter und so weiter da wäre wirklich
mal ein umdenken notwendig jetzt kommt
aber ihre genannten republik die sie ins
spiel gebracht haben
also die bürger hier ist der bürger ich
möchte noch ganz ganz kurz bevor ich
mich noch ganz kurz eine aussage von
ihnen zeigen herr lieber sie sind uns ja
aufgefallen und wir möchten ja in den
nächsten monaten hier viel öfter bürger
am tisch sitzen haben und ich möchte
dass einmal ganz kurz noch zeigen
jetzt haben wir gewissheit wir wissen
also jetzt dass wir nicht nur bei der
bundeswehr bei und energie bei unserer
gesamten infrastruktur komplett lang
sind so dass wir auch jetzt beim
wichtigsten überhaupt nämlich bei unser
selbstversorgung mit ernährung noch
komplett vermessen
wie soll ich sonst erklären dass ich ein
weizen gedroschen habe auf einen
absoluten spitze standort mit einem
proteingehalt von 8,8 prozent fallen sie
sich wissen damit kann zu keinen
brotbacken unmöglich selbst der beste
weg da draußen kann das nicht und wie
kommen wir zu diesen werten wie kommen
wir dazu dass aus allen
himmelsrichtungen deutschland gerade die
gleiche scheiße gemeldet werden ich habe
eine ganz konkrete frage was was würde
ihre arbeit erleichtern weil sie sagen
ihnen sind hände und füße gefesselt
könnten sie mir konkret sagen was das
ist wir bleiben noch einmal beim protein
kann ich bald darauf auch hier die frage
ja klar weil dann die frage wir haben
deutschland hat 2012 nach brüssel die
messwerte unser brunnen gemeldet also
unseres grundwassers und deutschland war
das einzige land was nicht wie alle
anderen länder den durchschnitt gemeldet
hat sondern wir haben nur die höchst
fertig meldet auf und aufgrund dessen
fußen bei uns drei düngeverordnung das
heißt wir müssen und müssen immer
weniger düngen das heißt wenn sie kleine
kinder haben dann braucht das kind 100
prozent des tagesbedarfs bei uns ist es
immer dass wir nur noch 80 prozent des
bedarfs der pflanzen düngen können und
erst jetzt mit drei dünne forderung das
soll jetzt nochmals verschärft werden
und aufgrund dessen ist ja wohl logisch
eine pflanze braucht genau wie ein
mensch eine bedarfsgerechte dir eh
nichts von überlegungen für reden von
einer bedarfsgerechten düngung und das
ist das ergebnis davon wir haben noch
nie einstellige werte im protein gehabt
sie müssen also gewissen na also ein
guter bäcker kriegs mit zehn prozent hin
zur wahrheit gehört auch das hängt von
der sorte ab und es gehört auch zur
wahrheit dass wir von der industrie
gezwungen wurden so hohe qualität wenn
ich erst mal platz sage wir bürgerinnen
die mich die nicht so bewandert ist eine
landwirtschaft das brot zerfließt also
beim bäcker auf dem backblech und ist
ungenießbar genauso ist es na klar und
wir haben es ja ich habe einen großen
mühlen gesprochen die haben gesagt wir
waren dieses jahr zum ersten mal in der
historie nicht in der lage dass wir uns
selbst autark mit brotbacken weizen
versorgen konnten wir mussten also dazu
kaufen ein sehr weit sein kann jetzt aus
den usa oder sommer kommt der her
könnten wir in deutschland uns ernähren
mit dem was passt da ist es verständlich
wenn es richtig gemacht verständnis die
menge ist da nur die qualität stimmten
diesen gar nicht genau was sind weil sie
ja die botschaft genau ist es noch
verrückter kommt aber jetzt und das ist
ein ding sie unbedingt loswerden muss
wir haben jetzt sensible gebiet nach
brüssel melden müssen sensible gebiete
heißt zum beispiel dass sie dort
nationalparks frankreich das gemacht der
nationalparks gemeldet die großen und
dort dürfen sie keine
pflanzenschutzmittel mehr einsetzen also
hört sie mir würde sagen pestizide und
wir schützen damit die pflanzen ist wie
medikament also es ist total irre dass
sie das nicht mehr einsetzen können
übrigens gilt das auch für bio bauern in
diesen bereichen da der biobauern uns
natürlich auch schwefel und kupfer
gerade im weinbau und nachlässe es geht
gar nicht ohne und wir haben wirklich
alle schutzgebiete selbst
landschaftsschutzgebiet meldet das heißt
also 60 prozent der fläche deutschlands
wäre damit betroffen das würde heißen
dass auf diesen flächen keine
landwirtschaft mehr möglich wäre und nur
mit einem sehr geringen ertrag na also
mit höherem aufwand bleiben geringeren
ertrag also wenn sie umstellen auf bio
na dann ernten sie maximal die hälfte
aber ich sagte er gerade selbst der
biobauer darf seine mittel die hier auch
ein selbst das ist ganz klar auch nicht
mehr einsetzen das heißt also dort haben
wir erträge wie im mittelalter wenn da
nicht direkt mit herrn özdemir reden die
regierung
natürlich müssen wir reden aber wir
jammern gehört das ist eine eine eine
geschichte dieser 2012 angewachsen ist
das ist jetzt neu mit den schutz mit den
sensiblen gebieten das ist neu da geht
es ja auch nicht um gm anfrage bietet
zum beispiel das ist ja das war ja noch
verrückter mit dem ab da gehen wir noch
einen das ist zu spezifisch wie geht's
jetzt wirklich nur um
pflanzenschutzmitteln dass ich das weg
ja auch korrigiert dänemark war wird
dünner genau die haben zehn jahre das
gemacht und haben gesagt mensch das
funktioniert es hinten freundlich wir
korrigieren das und würde ich sehe immer
so wir machen ja immer das gleiche
woanders schon fehler gemacht haben oder
wenn wir regen aus brüssel kriegen
setzen wir immer noch einen oben drauf
apropos brüssel vielleicht noch eine
antwort auf ihre frage ob die
landwirtschaftlichen durchqueren
natürlich werden wir das wir haben ja
gleichzeitig finanziell gefördert durch
die eu was weiß ich wie viele
hunderttausend hektar oder
quadratkilometer brachfläche dafür
bezahlt werden dass sie etwas brach
liegen lassen etwas anzubauen das ist
genau der punkt es ist ein wahnsinn also
jetzt wird uns gesagt auch wir mehr
beifall kam von uns in niedersachsen
gehören also auch von allen möglichen
parteien dass sie kriegt ja dafür ein
ausgleich wir wollen kein ausgleich wir
wollen doch unser und kulturlandschaft
die landwirte erschaffen haben und auch
nicht zur steppe verkommen lassen das
ist doch wahnsinn und wie willst du das
denn allen ernstes irgendwo auf der welt
erklären dass deutschland sonderweg geht
und alles kauft weil sie geld haben wie
können wir das moralisch mit ihren
christlichen glauben vertreten ich kann
das nicht und ich werde es auch nicht
machen frage was muss denn hier die fdp
tun
die muss sich diesen problemen annehmen
und muss dafür sorgen dass viele verbote
und hindernisse einfach aufgehoben
werden und es muss einfach auf neu
untersucht werden die die zahlen müssen
neu aufgestellt werden wenn sie sagen
das ist wir haben die wir haben
sozusagen die höchstzahlen genommen dann
muss die fdp jetzt
voran faschings wehrte sich erreicht
müsste die koalition platzen lassen na
das war ja mal was sie hatten ja viel
akkord war das würde ich jetzt sabrina
konrad carina konrad ist die
agrarpolitisch mehr in den bundestag die
sieht das genauso ich frage mich auch
nur warum die fdp sich nicht viele spd
mehr zusammen tun und da mal ganz klar
schaut hier geht es ja auch um unsere
unserem sozialen frieden um bezahlbare
lebensmittel die verknappen ja die wahl
wir müssen wir vielleicht wirklich mal
die die die ampel in schutz nimmt ja
noch nicht so viele monate am werk haben
keine zeit erst ein jahr lieber im
gewerbehaus probleme natürlich wie nie
und wir haben gerade ein kompromiss
erreicht um jetzt eben in dieser
situation der wir uns befinden wo ist
eine verknappung auf dem weltmarkt gibt
eben auch zu ermöglichen dass mehr
weizen produziert wird dass die
fruchtfolgen verändert werden also für
die leute da draußen dass man zweimal
hintereinander das selbe sehen da
normalerweise eben nicht mehr also dass
all diese dinge hätte ich diese tat von
sich auch entspannt also die können ja
nicht so behaupten dass überhaupt nichts
passieren würde in frisco rissig er sehe
wenn ich mit den bauern im wahlkreis
rede ich habe letzte woche auch wieder
mehrere besucher wir haben aus ddr
zeiten halt diese ehemaligen lpg ist und
recht große betriebe bei uns die eben
eher sagen naja wir möchten gerne
bessere haltungsform der verbraucher
möchte dass auch wir haben eben nur
probleme unsere stelle genehmigt zu
kriegen also wir alle unsere und das
sprechende haben der wirtschaftliche
standorte also ich sage wirklich da
müssen wir entbürokratisieren dass die
bauern wirklich vernünftige einheiten
haben wo die angeblichen richtige
haltung es geht alles so lange wir haben
eine bundeskanzler mit
richtlinienkompetenz das problem ist
aber der leiter halt nicht und dadurch
lassen dann gedenkt tierhalter ist ein
ganz wichtiger punkt ist diese woche hat
jetzt clemens tönnies ist ein anderes
thema klären jetzt hat ganz klar gesagt
wir werden das einfachste tierwohl itw
nicht mehr bezahlen wir reden hier von
sechs cent für ein kilo schweinefleisch
weil das an der ladentheke nicht mehr
gekauft wird und wir wissen jetzt alle
am regal mit die moral und deswegen
können wir so viel stelle umbauen wie
wir wollen der bürger hat gerade andere
probleme draußen der wirkt sich ein
regal tiefer und kauft das günstige wenn
wir jetzt hier in vorleistung treten
sollen welcher betrieb würden das machen
welcher selbständig würde sagen ich
trete diese vorleistungen investieren
anstatt für 200 jahre ohne gewissheit
das klappt kann menschen die müssen wir
irgendwie planungsleistungen haben dass
er daneben auch in 20 jahren ihren
return on invest habe genau weg mit
denen aber nehmen wir einmal ein
lösungsweg wenn jetzt sie heute kanzler
sind helga welche drei punkte sagen sie
die wissen sofort umgesetzt werden und
das hilft ihre lösung unsere lösung ist
ganz klar dass wir und ich hab's ja
gerade gesagt plastisch unserer hand
fest und lösen dass wir einfach auch
mehr vertrauen jeder landwirt jede
landwirten da draußen ist staatlich
ausgebildet also das kann ja nicht so
schlecht sein na ja und wie sagt er wir
haben die beste ausgebildete landwirte
der welt die machen keinen schnur
natürlich muss man überall regeln machen
das ja vollkommen klar aber also erster
punkteabbau raster punkt bürokratieabbau
sowie in jedem handwerk bürokratieabbau
die landwirte machen lassen dass wir
natürlich auch immer besser werden
können 24 jahren aber es gibt auch
folgendes wenn wir hier die
landwirtschaft nicht mehr machen macht
ein anderer viel schlechter was ist das
klima gewonnen was es für artenschutz
was für tirol gewonnen gar nicht zweiter
punkt nach zwei weiter vom zweiter punkt
ist ganz wichtig dass wir dieses
oligopol im lebensmitteleinzelhandel
diese riesen mächtigen die über 90
prozent marktanteil haben die
entscheidende mich was am regal landet
die bedienen sich auf der ganzen welt
kaufen das billigste ein unter der
einzige standard für lebensmittel die in
die eu kommen ist dass du nicht
gesundheitsgefährdend sein dürfen da
steht nicht mit tirol mit sozialen
standard gar nichts also da wünschen sie
sich mehr standen einander klar also
dann mehr regeln in dem fall die klar
also wir wir kämpfen doch mit völlig
verzerrten wettbewerb wie soll denn ein
obstbauer hier bei uns allen ernstes mit
dem marokkaner mithalten wie soll das
denn bitteschön gehen mit den hohen
standards mit mindestlohn das ist doch
nicht machbar das muss man auch jeden
bürger draußen class informiert dritter
punkt ist ich hätte noch tausende wenn
ich ganz ehrlich bin hin da war jetzt
nach erstes jahr das wir dass wir
einfach vertrauen von der politik
bekommen und ich hab's ja gerade gesagt
diese schutzgebiete die ich die wir
gemeldet haben daher ist in den 90er
jahren dass die bauern zusammen mit der
politik einen vertrag eingehen dass in
den schutzgebieten weiterhin
landwirtschaft betrieben werden kann das
ist jetzt mit füßen getreten worden das
ist eine faktische enteignung die auf
diesen betrieben auf diesen flächen darf
keine landwirtschaft mehr schatz den ich
möchte mal wissen wie das ist wenn
tatsächlich vw also gesagt wird ab
morgens feierabend wir müssen das
hinnehmen sie darf aber sie lohnt sich
vielleicht nicht mehr in die hand wenn
das ist quatsch das ist das ist nicht
mehr möglich das ist ungefähr das ist
für vw sagte kriegt jetzt einen dynamo
oder ihnen da muss ein fahrrad sitzen
dafür dass solarstrom das funktioniert
hinten und vorn nicht glauben sie mir
das ist wirklich wahr lösungs kleines
daran ich bin davon überzeugt dass
johannes eidt sich das sehr genau
anschauen wird weil du trittst ja immer
mitbürger den dialog das muss man ja
sagen auch in deinem eigenen wahlkreis
vielen dank für lösungsplan wir geben
eine ganz kurze werbepause aber die ist
ganz kurz nur und dann sind wir zurück
bis gleich
[Musik]
also da kann ich dann ein lauter krach
und nicht ernst nehmen als sogenannten
experten
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren bei
855 meinungen von jeder von uns hat ein
thema mitgebracht was ihn bewegt freut
oder schockiert
[Musik]
so nicht rüber chip buschi hergiswil
wetten
aber niemand von den politischen
parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen wir einfach nur freiheit diese
grün-roten der darm führen hochtrabende
debatten über die rettung des weltklimas
und um die füße russland die ratten das
thema ist viel zu wichtig um es nur
derart zu überlassen lasst den leuten
noch mal einen spaß wir sehen da etwas
was eigentlich fatale ist in der politik
bei den journalisten deren job ist es
doch gerade abweichende meinungen zu
fügen und sie sollen den doch auch
richtig dürfte sein dass das gehirn
eines conti zum manko vielleicht einmal
kurz ein
doch das ist übliche anorak träger aus
dem studienbeginn ist ich habe meinen
beifall um eine sache immer bekommt er
kümmert sich darum niemand tut es
man ist ja ganz knapp drüber sprechen
das einfach nicht fertig richtig durch
die ausgabe von journalismus einfach
die verlautbarungen der politik zu
hinterfragen
[Musik]
wir sind zurück und haben ja schon zwei
große themen heute angesprochen 3 sogar
die masken fläche in flugzeugen dann
haben wir die landwirtschaft gesprochen
und natürlich haben wir auch noch
darüber gesprochen was ich in diesem
land ändern muss bezüglich der öko
diktatur aber jetzt kommt die vierte
wichtige these leute haben und die kommt
von josef kraus und betrifft den
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk
ja
ja wo fange ich an
einerseits hat mich maßlos geärgert was
jetzt herausgekommen ist
andererseits freue ich mich dass diese
wandlitz blase von öffentlich
rechtlichen rundfunk libellen dran wird
vielleicht kommen andere noch nach
endlich geplatzt ist endlich geplatzt
ist wir haben das teuerste öffentlich
rechtliche rundfunk und fair gewesen auf
der welt mit 8,4 milliarden jährlich
zwangs finanziert bei 100 millionen
werbeeinnahmen kommen noch mit dazu ja
und werde ich sage wandlitz blase
wandnischen rom diejenigen die ddr ein
bisschen kennen müssen was das bedeutet
ganz schlimm viertel wandlitz da durfte
man nicht reinschauen die haben mit west
gütern da und mit westfernsehen
natürlich alles gehabt in saus und braus
und haben auch volvo s gefahren
vielleicht auch mit massagesitzen ich
weiß es nicht es ist gut dass das
endlich geplatzt ist weil hier der fall
eine sogenannte mediale elite
völlig abgehoben hat völlig abgehoben
hat mit gehältern und boni wie weit das
übersteigen was ein bundespräsident und
der bundeskanzler bekommt mit direktoren
mit jahresgehältern von 180000 240.000
euro weit über dem was ein minister
werde in den minister zum beispiel in
einem bundesland mit großer
verantwortung hat das stimmt was nicht
da stimmt was nicht und dass da endlich
ränge leuchtet wurde und die hoffe dass
die staatsanwaltschaften das noch zu und
ich wünsche mir vor allem auch dass die
kontrollgremien
die es dort gibt es gibt verwaltungsräte
es gibt fernsehgeräte dass sie endlich
mal ihr job nachkommen aber sie sind
sofort sein sid sie sind nach einem
proporzsystem die ngo muss bedient
werden die partei muss bedient werden
die kirche muss bedient werden sind
susanne gebastelt worden keine ausnahmen
auch sie können auch einen ganz
besonders dem bayerischen rundfunk rat
sitzt ja der sich auch sehr kritisch
geäußert denn wenn sie sich inzwischen
so austauschen bildet die ausnahme die
ausnahme die sie sagen antworten
markwort hat sich keine freunde gemacht
im rund fliege
ich frage mich wo war der rundfunkrat
war wo war die vorschrift des
rundfunkrates die ja nun mittlerweile
auch twitter ist es noch einmal zusammen
für die zuschauer dies vielleicht
mitbekommen haben den fall schlesinger
das muss man ja wir haben zusammen die
frau schlesinger hat boni noch nicht
mitgerechnet ein jahreseinkommen von
300.000 euro gehabt das halte ich für
schon ein bisschen obst schön ich jetzt
in dem vergleich mit bundespräsident und
und bundeselterngeld das kam in weit kam
ohne mittel dazu sei es brauchen wir
eine luxus güte mit dazu autos mit
massagesitzen es kamen offensichtlich an
den üblichen ausschreibungsverfahren mit
hinzu
millionenbeträge für die
neuausstattung eines büros private feste
auch die den upgrade fahrerin ja während
übrigens der kleine redakteur oder der
freie feste freie mitarbeiter relativ
dürftig aber draußen lässt schlesinger
wurde ja auch abberufen kann man das
vielleicht auch als wendepunkt sehen es
war das erste mal und hoffe das ist ein
wendepunkt jemand ab wo die gruppe das
in der zdf-reihe leuchtet wird die gdf
hat die größe und trocken ich glaube man
muss auch sagen dass nicht in allen
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunkanstalten
der länder also solche bedingungen sind
die bedingungen
also rein geleuchtet habe ich möchte
eingeleuchtet haben am ende ergab weiß
inventur und da sind die 200 minisender
warum müssen wie radio bremen haben und
sie müssen wir saarländischen rundfunk
haben warum kann man die nicht
zusammenpassen aber ist das weiß ja
nicht was ich mir gerade vor stelle ich
meine die falsche lösung ist schon ein
herausragender fall aber ich glaube
nicht dass sie ein einzelfall ist und
ich stelle mir ist jetzt schon fast
bildlich vor wie in den verschiedenen
sendern die intendanten die direktoren
und sonst welche führungskräfte
verzweifelt sagen oh gott den stuhl
gestellt den stuhl sofort wird er ab
diesen tollen stuhl diesen beruf stuhl
da werden ja schon renovierungen von
büros werden schon wieder zurückgenommen
und was sind man den berühmten
massagestuhl in dem dienstwagen betrifft
in der ich gehöre ja zu fast zur
pflichtausstattung
ich denke aber vor dass diese diese
diese umgang mit öffentlichen geldern
ist es sind ja öffentliche gelder die
wir bezahlen dass ich glaube dass da
verschließen
die 18 euro der muss er nass das
absitzen auch diese fälle haben wir nein
ich möchte dass der weg beschritten wird
wie es teilweise die franzosen
eingeschlagen haben ja sie waren die
rundfunkgebühren abschaffen ja ich
möchte sie abschaffen ich möchte keine
mehr die cs angaben konkurrenzkampf
zwischen den privaten haben und den
öffentlich-rechtlichen haben oder sage
ich noch etwas wir haben aber einen
doppelten verfassungsrechtlichen schutz
also die rechtlichen grundlagen sind
völlig andere und ich finde es auch gut
dass wir eine medienlandschaft haben die
öffentlich-rechtliche und private sender
hat hier wie in deutschland die sich
auch ein bisschen ergänzen die ein
bisschen anderes profil haben wo ich ein
recht gebe also ich finde auch 300 3000
euro für eine intendantin einer
landesrundfunkanstalt das muss nicht
sein aber auch dort ist es so dass die
so geschützt sind durch
verfassungsgerichtliche urteile das
altehrwürdige hören zwar mit dem urteil
auf wir haben also staatsvertrag die
haben wir auch dort heißt es dass alle
einer gebühr erhöhung zustimmen müssen
dann stimmt das land sachsen-anhalt
dagegen beziehungsweise macht das nicht
mit und dann haben wir diesen ersten
senat angeführt von einem gewissen herrn
professor hart ja ehemals
stellvertretender cdu csu
fraktionsvorsitzender und merkel
juristischer merkel berater und so
weiter und dann wird das einfach und
sicher ein weil er mal eben merkel
berater war ich glaube die
unabhängigkeit des verfassungsgerichts
sollten wir jetzt hier nicht ein
erklärte das verfassungsgericht hat sie
selbst ihr renommee erspielt haben
nämlich das klima urteil dann nehme ich
die kanone urteil hast windows alles dem
kaminfeuer kranke urteile und inhalt wie
gewaltenteilung funktionieren kommen
auch mal das verfassungsgericht das
versprechen aber jetzt reden wir einmal
über den inhalt und zwar folge mit ihnen
will ich schon sein sitzt hier auch eine
insiderin am tisch leer wie lange die
bambi-verleihung gemeinsam mit dem
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk
ausgerichtet ungefähr 20 jahre 20 jahre
da werden sie auch viele kennen gelernt
haben wie empfinden sie denn den
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk ganz
persönlichen auch das programm dort
das ist eine schwierige frage ich schaue
sehr viel fernsehen
ich liebe die dritten programme
ich liebe auch arte
und ich gucke mir da also viele
sendungen an dem ebit ist persönlich
gefallen
aber das was einmal ob das öffentlich
rechtliche fernsehen seinem seinem
kulturellen auftrag nach kommt das
möchte ich dann schon doch in vielen
fällen bezweifeln ja in welchen fällen
zum beispiel wann immer es um serien
geht um filme usw also ich könnte mir
vorstellen dass der
öffentlich-rechtliche auftrag
sehr viel mehr
kultur sehr viel mehr politik und sehr
viel mehr
wissenssendungen bedeuten sollte und war
nicht mehr zum beispiel nein das kann
ich jetzt nicht ich kann ich sagen diese
eine sendung ist jetzt schlecht oder
brauchen wir tatort ja ich würde sehr
gern
eine chandler sprachliche erziehung
durch die öffentliche rechtliche und
darum ging es dann doch war es war eine
wunderbare sendung es wurde uns
vorgeworfen dass wir damit reklame für
den burda-verlag machen aber
letztendlich war barbie eine eine
preisverleihung für menschen mit
herausragenden fähigkeiten
talenten oder
visionen aber wird aus den menschen
gesagt haben das wäre für sie lieber
beim privatfernsehen weil sie finde der
öffentlich rechtliche auftrag es ist
nicht nein also dass das fand ich dann
schon das fand ich schon okay weil das
wir haben ja auch
das wort einer reinen
unterhaltungssendung haben wir das so
einem ganz ganz anderen sendung
gestaltet ja also es war sehr viel mehr
inhalt und sehr viel mehr
ernsthaftigkeit dass das finde ich schon
in ordnung aber ich
glaube einfach dass das die
das ist eine gewisse großmannssucht eine
verschwundene eine freude an der
verschwendung und kein und kein
verhältnis so zu öffentlichen geldern in
vielen sendern gibt ja also das wird
einfach ausgegeben und es wird immer
mehr verlangt es sollten die gebühren
sollen erhöht werden und im übrigen
übernehmen natürlich auch die
öffentlich-rechtlichen sendern auch sehr
viele bereiche die eigentlich nur die
privaten haben sollten ja also ein handy
ich hinschauen sie dennoch öffentlich
rechtliches verläuft weil wir so unter
wasser dass ganz so effektoren sie ist
gerne mit meinen schwiegereltern das
gucken muss weil wohl unter einem haus
als katastrophe aber mir geht's ja was
werden sie denn gezwungen tagesschau
aber schon heute
das ganze warum also mir geht es nicht
nur um das geld ja ich will wäre
tatsächlich bereit als normaler bürger
auch das geld zu bezahlen aber ich habe
kein hundertprozentiges vertrauen mehr
zum öffentlichen rechtlichen rundfunk
ich sage ihnen auch warum weil ich das
einmal als sich aus eines eben mal die
polizei war der junge war sehr dass
viele dinge einfach ich behaupte mal
bewusst verschwiegen werden zwei
landwirtschaft ein absolut dramatisches
thema es geht immer nur in eine richtung
es wird immer nur drauf grauen von 99
sendungen sind wirklich oder von 100
sendungen 99 wirklich gegen
landwirtschaft bewusst und nicht fakten
orientiert als beste beispiel waffen es
war ein riesiger und journalistischen ja
ich bin ein linkslastig ich würde ein
wenig fühlt sich
links liegen zu lassen also da ist es
ist es ist fremming ist es ja ein
bewusstes franken und zwar das beste
beispiel war die hatten ja gut für
die demokratie aber irgendwie haben muss
man sagen ist der öffentlich-rechtliche
rundfunk auch die quellenkritik
wesentlich besser geworden dem gesagt
wird aber um gelangen können wenn ich
nach aber eine rechtliche rundfunk hatte
bislang an man muss schon sagen wenn man
sieht interviews mit selensky wenn man
sieht ich möchte jetzt nicht mein
eigenes haus loben und meinen kollegen
paul ronzheimer aber alle exklusiven
informationen kamen fast ausnahmslos von
bauern sammer und der bild oder wenn man
sagt der öffentlich rechtliche auftrag
also ich wollte nur sagen das ist wenn
kritik weil sie gesagt habe der
öffentlich rechtlichen fonds und
kritisch ja ich doch dass man mit auch
gut informiert wirst sie ihren freund
einseitig kritisch und ich habe ihm
gesagt also ja es soll nochmals die
affinität von 80 prozent der
journalisten im öffentlich rechtlichen
bereich an die untersuchungen von
professor kettwiger die umfrage und der
volontären die in der ard ja da machen
rot grün 80 prozent und das merkt man
auch bisher in unterhaltungssendungen es
gibt doch fast keinen
tatort mehr der nicht auf wo knecht
getrimmt ist auch schon ihr habt sollte
sehr guten geschaut aber wir müssen
jetzt somit ein einkommen bei rtl auf
seine these mitgebracht da muss ich
ihnen widersprechen
tatort bin ich den liebhaberinnen von
man muss auch mal ein punkt den anderen
medien geben und damit zu ihnen halt
vielen dank der molly einsatz ist der
größte einsatz der bundeswehr wir haben
dort 4400 soldaten vor ort wir sind über
zehn jahre dort ich bin selber dreimal
im einsatz dort gewesen und ich bin der
meinung wir sollten uns jetzt ganz
geplant und langsam abziehen werden bei
der mandatsvergabe gesagt wir überprüfen
das quasi wir geben noch mal ein jahr
zeit und es gibt gewisse bedingungen wo
wir uns dann überlegen den einsatz zu
beenden und meine argumente sind wie
folgt ich finde wir können den auftrag
dort nicht wahrnehmen ja wir haben also
die möglichkeit ein bisschen auf
tagesbasis beurteilen ob wir unseren
auftrag erfüllen können für diese
un-mission die un-missionen kann unter
den derzeitigen bedingungen mit der
putschregierung keine stabilität und
keine stabile arbeit umsetzen den
friedensprozess nicht vorantreiben und
außerdem ist die sicherheit der soldaten
natürlich auch mittelbar gefährdet
dadurch dass wir quasi immer wieder
überfluggenehmigungen nicht erhalten die
golden aber nicht einhalten können und
damit eben die operationelle beim range
sehr limitiert ist vom lager hat ich bin
der meinung wir sollten dort geplant
abziehen aber im rahmen der zeit müssen
wir unsere verantwortung auch wahrnehmen
das heißt wir müssen gleichzeitig
überlegen geben wir vielleicht auch
wieder rein mit einem neuen mandat mit
einer ganz zugeschnittene aufgabe mit
zielen die wir haben und einem klaren
zeitablauf was passiert denn wenn die
bundeswehr abzieht was passiert dann das
ist natürlich wir sind im rahmen der
un-mission minustah eingebettet das sind
ungefähr 15.000 soldaten
wir sind eine der nationen die die
hochwertigsten fähigkeiten dort stellt
das natürlich ein schwerer schlag und
darum sind wir auch noch da aber das
außen- und sicherheitspolitische wichtig
ist dass wir da sind aber wir müssen
natürlich auch überlegen was für mandat
haben wir vom un sicherheitsrat also was
sollen wir dort lösen und ich sehe im
moment nicht dass wir das dass wir eben
stabilität dem friedensprozess von als
ja dort weiter bringen in der jetzigen
lage und ich sehe auch nicht dass sich
das absehbar verändern wird
nichtsdestotrotz müssen wir stabilität
in die region bringe das machen wir zum
beispiel in niger mit der operation
taguba wo wir eben niedriges militär
ausbilden aber mit klaren qualitätsstufe
nur wissen wo wir sagen in einem jahr
ist es vorbei dass wir uns auch ganz
klar wirklich evaluieren was wir dort
wirklich tun sie sind ja experte auch
für die thematik und b eigentlicher für
auslandseinsätze aber wie sehen sie das
hier in dem zusammenhang also was heißt
erklärte gut ich war vor langer zeit
waren die beiden herren noch gar nicht
auf der welt war ich heute bei der
luftwaffe war im schlaf weiter gespart
und dann war ich 22 jahre lang mitglied
im beirat für in der führung des
verteidigungsminister kann man sie als
experten bezeichnen so anna muster haben
die letzte erlebt da habe ich auch
drucken mit dem ausland besucht im
kosovo und so weiter und so weiter mehr
ich war ab 92 in diesem beirat
und ich war von den auslandseinsätzen
bis einschließlich zuletzt afghanistan
und morde überzeugt aber ich teile jetzt
ihre auffassung der major wenn ich sie
so ansprechen darf nachdem die franzosen
als die führende und stärkste kraft dort
mit 4000 soldaten abgezogen sind und
nachdem putin
personal ist jetzt erstmal so mit seiner
gruppe wagner dort einmarschiert muss es
und der verteidigungsministerin und dem
bundeskanzler und der generalität um die
fürsorgepflicht für unsere soldaten
gehen und dann muss es heißen raus damit
welche bäder erwarten uns denn johannes
wenn ich daran denke was uns nach
afghanistan erwartet hat das war ja
schon auch als bürgerin entsetzlich zu
sehen wenn wir aus mali rausgehen was
erwartet uns dann und nicht dass wir die
bilder schlümpfen zu ertragen sein was
erwartet natürlich die menschen vor ort
es gibt eine studie vom april die sagt
dass wir vor allen dingen im nahbereich
der bases quasi wirklich sicherheit
erzeugen und für die menschen sicherheit
verbessern aber nur in diesem bereich
der base empfinden wir eine verbesserte
sicherheit ich glaube wenn wir dort
abziehen müssen wir das wirklich geplant
tun also nicht in wenigen wochen sondern
sagen wir machen das auch über ein
prozess mehrere monate sich zum beispiel
afghanischer seite wo wir schützen
personal wir nehmen unsere sprachmittler
unsere lokalen angestellten mit und
deren familien um die müssen wir uns
kümmern das ist ein ganz ganz wichtiges
thema
bleiben wie soll man das lösen wie ich
hab das ja gesagt ich möchte mich der
verantwortung nicht entziehen weil das
heißt zeiten da auch wir müssen endlich
sicherheitspolitisch erwachsenwerden und
das habe ich das gefühl sind wir
manchmal noch nicht wir müssen also
darüber nachdenken wie können wir diese
region weiterhelfen aber mit einem
begrenzten mandat mit klaren aufgaben
und auch ganz ganz kleinen qualitäts
messpunkten das wäre mir sehr wichtig
dass wir also über beides nachdenken
abzug jetzt weil so bringt es nichts
aber überlegen wie wir vielleicht das
problem weiter brauchen wir noch einen
weiteren perspektivenwechsel ja die
bundeswehr war ab 1990 91 92 sehr stark
fokussiert auf auslandseinsätze und hat
die landesverteidigung
vernachlässigt ja personal abgebaut
friedensdividende zugunsten von
sozialpolitischen wohltaten und wir
wissen ja manche waffensysteme haben nur
eine einsatzfähigkeit von 40 45 prozent
bestimmt der hubschrauber und so weiter
wer nachwuchsproblem 20 tausend
dienstposten sind nicht besetzt
gleichzeitig wollen wir von 183.000 auf
203.000 kommen weiß gar nicht wo die
alle herkommen sollen das personal der
macht das 40.000 ja da muss man diese
perspektiven perspektive wechseln mit
machen ja auch wieder nicht zuletzt
wegen ukraine
ich bin ich bin der meinung wir sollten
diesen fehler von anfang 90er jahre
nicht wiederholen also wir jetzt sagen
wir vergessen jetzt auf einmal
auslandseinsätze und machen nur noch
landes und bündnisverteidigung ist jetzt
will er muss der schwerpunkt liegen aber
wir müssen weiter noch die kleine insel
ich glaube beides gleichberechtigt wird
wahrscheinlich schwer werden mit den
kräften und nichts über den aber wir
müssen die fähigkeiten in beiden
bereichen behalten und bei bedarf eben
auch das ausland als wäre das stichwort
erreichen die 100 milliarden nicht die
100 milliarden reichen vielleicht jetzt
die nächsten vier jahre um das 2 prozent
nahezu zu 100 milliarden ja dazu quasi
dass wir wieder das auffüllen was wir
jetzt viele jahre aus den regalen
wieder unterbrechen aber unsere
sendezeit ist zu ende und über sondern
sprechen vielleicht morgen haben ganz
herzlichen dank an patricia riekel die
saas die mich vor genau einem jahr auch
schon hier bei heute wird finden nach 8
1 jahr alt hoffentlich dann zum zweiten
ist vorrückt auch wieder das ja und da
[Musik]